NICOLAS ROARD: Good
morning, everyone.
My name is Nicolas Roard.
I'm a software engineer
on the Android team.
And I've been working on the
Android WebView and, by
extension, the Android browser
for the last few years.
So what I'm going to talk about
today is mostly a bit of
the [INAUDIBLE]
mechanisms for the WebView, how
we implemented the view.
And the second part is mostly
about so how can take
advantage of that to make your
application smoother
and nicer to use.
All right, so WebKit one, for
the probably very few that
don't know what is, it
was our [INAUDIBLE]
project by the KDE desktop
environment.
And they use that for
their own browser.
And Apple took KHTML, that
they're conjoined, and
extended it and made it more
robust, and used that as a
base for Safari.
And more to the interest for us,
in 2008, both Chrome used
an enjoined based on WebKit, and
the Android used both the
browser and the WebView
also using WebKit.
One of the interesting thing
with Android is that the
Android browser is actually
just using the WebView.
So it's exactly the same thing
that you can use in your
applications.
So let's talk a bit about
the architecture.
So WebKit.
So roughly, you've
got two parts.
You've got layout engine,
something that can take some
content and determine
where it wants to
put the various elements.
And you've got JavaScriptCore,
which is a JavaScript engine
that will do whatever it
wants on the page.
And those two things are our
equipment, they're the Android
Elf WebKit.
Right, so how it works, slightly
in more details.
So let's say that
you get WebKit.
You are going to get
some resources.
You're going to send them to
WebKit, or WebKit was going to
load them more exactly.
And WebKit's going to
build a document
object model using that.
Execute unique JavaScript that
has to be executed on the
document object model.
And finally, do the layouts
and everything
that needs to be done.
So what is interesting to us is
that WebKit is actually a
very abstract engine and
platform-specific bits and
stuff like rendering
are nicely put into
the category platform.
And from that you can get
the final rendering.
Right, so in platforms,
what do we get?
We have the network and disk
access, of course.
You have some system
integration.
And by that, I'm mostly thinking
about the newest
HTML5 APIs, stuff like
camera access or
Geolocation, or whatnot.
And of course, that's
+1 dependent.
And the big part of this stuff
today is going to be more
about the graphics and
the rendering.
Because that's really where
you can see a difference
between the different WebKit
implementations.
And finally, you can also
possibly replace the default
JavaScript engine of WebKit by
something else, which is
actually what we did.
We are using V8, the same
engine as Chrome.
OK, so quickly about the
system integration.
Those are some of the API that
we added on previous releases
of Android.
If you are using the WebView in
your application, I think
that you can be interested in
our HTML5 video support, and
Geolocation API.
But anyway, roughly it will
be released this week.
We tried to add more support
for those kind of APIs.
All right, our JavaScript,
just to
give you on the WebView.
On the same device, you can
see that, well luckily, we
improved from release
to release.
And in JellyBean on the Nexus
S, you are a bit more than
twice as fast as Gingerbread
was.
Interestingly, if you compare
that to a laptop, and that's a
2.5 gigahertz core
[INAUDIBLE].
The Galaxy Nexus is only five to
six times slower, which if
you think about it
is not that slow.
I mean, we are getting closer
and closer to [INAUDIBLE]
that you got on a desktop
a few years ago.
All right, so rendering.
And again, that's mostly where
things differ in terms of the
WebKit implementation.
Everyone is using WebKit.
WebKit is used by so many
different companies.
And where things differ is
how you implement the
platform-specific bits that
decide how you want to render
stuff on screen.
So if you remember that,
basically that corresponds to
something like that, in terms
of a rendering loop.
You got [INAUDIBLE] event,
like scroll.
You are going to interaction to
that, paint something like
a bitmap in the [INAUDIBLE],
something that.
And that's going to
be your content.
And finally, you want to draw
that content on screen.
And of course, you do that
over and over again.
Visually, that corresponds
to that.
That's an individual document.
We are going to work with what
you call the viewport, which
is simply the visible part
of your document.
And actually live, that's
exactly how WebKit sees
things, is that nothing that is
not shown on the screen is
actually painted.
You only paint what's visible.
So the problem with that is if
you scroll around, you have to
repaint this area.
And that's an issue on mobile,
because it's a very tight loop
and it can be slow.
So what we did on Android
before in Honeycomb was
instead of implementing this
action/reaction of repainting
stuff as we are going on.
Instead, we capture the content
of the page into what
we call the picture.
And then using that picture,
we can render it.
OK, so why did we do that?
Because the picture is
basically a vector
representation of the page,
which is nice because then it
means you can do stuff like
scrolling just by moving the
transform of when you replay
the driving instructions.
Or you can zoom without having
to go back to WebKit.
And that's good because if
WebKit was only doing
painting, that would be fine.
But WebKit of course is doing a
lot of other stuff, loading
documents, doing layouts,
anything like that.
So if you depend from WebKit
to get reasonable
performances, you
missed it here.
Because you're going to send
[INAUDIBLE] onto WebKit
saying, hey, repaint me this
part of the screen.
And WebKit is saying, sure,
but hold on, I'm doing
something else.
So by adding this split
architecture with the picture
on one side and WebKit on the
other, we can do our things on
UI, and let WebKit do
it's own things.
So and that's for securities,
right?
We've got two different threads,
the WebCore thread
and the UI thread.
We have a picture that we use on
the UI thread to render the
page on screen.
So if we send an event from
the UI, like it's called
Gesture, or [INAUDIBLE],
something like that.
We send it to do a core
thread WebCore.
We engineer it in your
picture, send the
picture off to us.
We can then use that
one to show the new
content to the user.
Right, so this is nice, but
there is some issues.
One of the main--
and I believe that most of you
have experienced that on your
Android devices is
that the speed is
dependent on the content.
Meaning that on some websites,
you're going to be able to
scroll very smoothly, very
quickly, the user interaction
is going to be nice.
And then you go to a different
website, and the websites is
not responsive.
And that's because of
this, because we are
replaying this picture.
And if you have too many drawing
instructions, or if
the drawing instructions are too
slow to rasterize to get
your final image, then you're
going to take longer than 16
millisecond, and you're going
to be visibly slow.
The other thing is that it's
a purely 2D model.
So if you want to support things
like your CSS3D, you're
out of luck.
And the last thing is that if
you remember with the plugins,
such as flash, you could scroll
around and the flash
plugin was kind of trailing
behind you or your scroll.
And that's because it's an
asynchronous rendering model,
and it's difficult to
synchronize both because one
doesn't know where
the other is.
Anyhow, on Honeycomb,
we [INAUDIBLE]
that.
So the reason is because our
screen size increase.
The whole restoration thing in
software didn't work out.
So what we did instead,
we just take content.
So the idea is that if you take
that rendering loop, you
really, really, really want that
loop to be done in less
than 16 milliseconds.
That corresponds to 60 FPS.
The problem with this is that if
the paint, as I explained,
takes longer than that, then
you are out of luck.
And visibly, you'll see
something like that.
You're going to scroll, but
it's going to stutter.
So ideally, you want something,
you know, I scroll,
I draw, that's it.
And that's basically what
hardware rendering is.
So starting from Honeycomb
WebView, as long as your
application interacts
with the mode, it's
going to use that mode.
And what you do, you scroll,
you draw, and
you draw your tiles.
And of course, what you
do is you move things
into different threads.
When you scroll, you send the
command saying, hey, paint me
the new content, the
one I just uncover.
And it give me new tiles.
But the nice thing, of course,
is that as it's tying
different thread, if that
operation takes time, it
really doesn't matter.
So here's how it
looks visually.
You've got a viewport.
We're going to prepare
some new tiles.
We are going to use them
to display the
content to the user.
If the user is scrolling, we
prepare some new tile.
But we don't have to wait for
the rendering loop, right?
So we can just start scrolling
around, even if some of the
tiles are not there,
doesn't matter.
We can take the tiles that are
now hidden and reuse then to
get some new content.
So that's roughly the
general idea.
And so on and so forth.
In terms of the architecture,
we just add the new thread.
When we create the picture
on the WebKit thread.
We send that to the UI, send it
to the Texture Generation
thread, use that to generate the
texture, send the texture
to the UI, and the UI can
directly use those textures.
And that's it.
The nice thing with this model
is that, again, we are
completely separated
from WebKit.
And we can be completely
independent.
So we can still do all the
zooming, scrolling and all
that without having to
go back to WebKit.
We still have the entire page
content inside the picture.
So we still take advantage of
that to be able to generate
text very quickly.
So the problem with this is we
are basically doing exactly
the same job as before.
And on top of that, we
have to upload the
content to the textures.
So basically, you're going
to get slower painting
performances with this
architecture.
But you're going to get much
faster drawing performances.
Obviously, to try to hide that
we do lots of things.
Like we try to pre-cache the
tiles in the direction where
you're scrolling.
We schedule some tiles that are
at the lower resolution so
that they can [INAUDIBLE]
for us to cover a large area.
So that's why on the browser
you can see some blurry
content sometimes if you
scroll too fast.
But at least we show
you something.
Now, of course we are limited
by the memory, and that's
dependent on the device.
One thing that I'll talk about
later but you can think about
is the tiles are 256
by 256 so far.
And that's also an implication
in how you can use that to
tailor your content.
One thing we do in JellyBean as
well is we do some check.
If the tiles are completely
empty, we don't use a texture
for that, we just use a drawing
shader and just have
some textures, and that
improves some of the
performances.
OK, so that's the rough idea on
how WebKit works in terms
of rendering.
And then someone decided that,
oh yeah, we can create this
thing called layers.
So layers, the general idea is
that you've got your page,
you've got some content on
the page, and you want to
translate that image, you want
to animate it on screen.
If you do that, what's going to
happen is that think about
it as a base surface.
And you're going to have to
invalidate and repaint this
entire area on the surface
because that's
where you move stuff.
And it's even worse because
you are not doing that in
single frame, you are doing
that in as many frames you
need for the animation.
So the idea of layers is to
say, well, let's get that
element onto it's own surface.
So now we don't have a
single surface, we
have multiple surfaces.
And then we can just draw that
at draw time when we want to
show the content to the user.
And if you think about it, if
we do that in [INAUDIBLE],
it's nearly a preparation.
We just draw different quads and
the GPU card is doing the
heavy work, and surface move.
So that's the idea of layers.
The other thing that you can
do with layers is better
support some of the
HTML content.
One example is this.
You got the web page, you got
a video on the page, and you
got [INAUDIBLE]
section with images that
you can scroll around.
The normal model would be for
the scrolling around, every
time you scroll around to
repainting this area.
And that's not super fast.
And if you have this hardware
rendering pipeline, it's even
slower because, well, on top
of everything, we have to
upload a texture.
So what you do instead, you
think those two things-- the
video and the scrollable
elements--
and you move them out
of the base surface
onto their own layer.
The next thing is that for the
scrollable layer, you can then
not just pre-pain the stuff that
is currently on screen,
but you can paint the
entire element.
Then you just have to clip
when you draw it.
And that's it.
The nice thing is you don't have
to go back to web page,
you don't have to invalidate,
you don't have to repaint, and
things are smooth.
Right.
So on this previous page, this
is how it would look like in
terms of WebKit.
It would have the base surface,
the base layer.
We'd have one video
layer, clip layer,
and scrollable layer.
The good thing with the video
layer is that if you remember
what I was explaining earlier
about the flash plugin, you
want stuff to be synchronized.
The problem that we had before
is that we didn't know where
it was, or we knew too late
because rendering was
asynchronous.
In this model, we just say, oh
well, be on your own layer.
And then it just happen that
when we draw this layer, we're
not choosing the texture.
More exactly, we are directly
asking the media server to
give us video texture,
and we show that.
So we control entirely
where things are.
And therefore, things are
fully synchronous.
All right, so layers, basically,
they are great.
And if there is one thing you
should remember about this
talk it's use layers.
And I'm going to go into more
details about how you can do
that in your application.
But basically, as I explain, you
can move them around and
it's very cheap.
And what I said before about
the foreign content.
Originally the idea with layers
was not even that.
The idea for layers in WebKit
was to implement CSS 3D.
So CSS 3D, for the ones
who don't know, it's
something like that.
You've got some 3D transforms
that are applied to elements.
So here, for example, all those
little rectangles are
just developments.
You just apply a CSS transform,
and that's it.
Just another example,
got a rotating cube.
And you can do all kinds
of fun things.
And basically, you can use
that to maybe make user
interface nicer to the user,
or more interactive.
Anyhow, on Android, we
implemented the support for
that in the WebView
since Honeycomb.
But we also used it to
do other things.
So what we did for the
architecture, we basically
took the previous architecture
and we said, OK, instead of
giving us just a single
texture, give
us a tree of layers.
And each layer will contain--
I'm simplifying a bit--
but actually, it will
contain a picture.
The thing you notice
here is that I
added the CSS animation.
So CSS animation is a
pretty cool think.
It's something that lets you
specify an animation, you
know, decently high-level way.
And you can do pretty
complex things.
It's supported on Firefox and
WebKit-based browsers.
The nice thing with that is that
instead of letting WebKit
doing the valuation for the
animation and determining
where you want an element to
be according t that, we can
take this computation and
move it to the UI.
And basically, that means that
those animations are hardware
accelerated.
Sorry.
And if you have heard a bit
about the [INAUDIBLE]
and stuff.
That also means that those
animations are v-synced.
So they are nice [INAUDIBLE].
And of course, they are much,
much faster than JavaScript.
You don't need to execute
anything.
It's all done on the UI side.
It's all synchronous.
But I mean to simplify things,
try to use CSS animations.
On this example, the way you
do that, you just create an
animation, say where
you want it to be
and apply your transform.
And that's all.
And that's what was giving you
this whole spin thing.
So on Android, we used this
concept of layers and
leveraged it to make
the content nicer.
So one pretty simple thing that
we did and that was back
in [INAUDIBLE]
was to support fixed positioned
elements.
And fixed positioned elements
are those elements on the web
page that basically don't move
when you scroll around.
And we implemented a bunch of
other things, like the HTML5
video, the iFrame support,
OverFlow-scroll elements, of
course the CSS 3D, and even
fixed background elements.
So that gives you something
that if I take the I/O
website, you got this
fixed element.
And you see that it's
scrolling smoothly.
And the reason is because
that element on
top is a fixed element.
We don't have to go
back to WebKit.
We can just do the compositing
and the positioning on the UI
when we want to draw a frame.
But that's just the fixed
background element.
You can see that the background
of that element is
actually another image.
That image doesn't move, and you
can still scroll around.
Anyway, you can do a lot
of interesting things.
Basically, what we're using is
the same code path as for the
base layer, what I was
describing earlier.
And we have the same
constraints.
We tried to do a couple of
clever things to help you with
that, because if you generate
too many layers, that can be
an issue in terms of memory.
So we try to merger layers
if we can, and a couple
of things like that.
All right, so that was all about
describing how stuff
worked in [INAUDIBLE].
Now, how can you take advantage
of that to make your
stuff faster?
So basically, the WebView is
something that lets you
display [INAUDIBLE]
and content.
You can consider that it has a
desktop HTML support level.
And it can do all kind
of cool stuff.
Right.
Yeah, that's basically
what we added on
the different versions.
Let me go quickly because I
think I'm running a bit late.
So you use that basically
like a normal view.
It's just another widget.
If you want to load content from
the internet, you have to
use a permission, obviously.
You may have to override
the WebViewClient if
you want to do that.
Loading content is as simple as
specifying URL or injecting
some HTML directly.
You may want to enable
JavaScript.
And basically, in terms of the
rending, you've got those two
different modes.
You've got these hardware
rendering mode that I was
talking about.
You still have the software
rendering mode.
And it's still there
for a reason.
Sometimes it's going to be much
more memory efficient
than using the hardware
rendering.
Basically, if you have content
that's not very much, you are
not going to be taking much
advantage of the rotating
architecture.
See, if your content won't move,
you don't really care.
And in that case, it might be
much faster, and even as
you're repainting stuff,
than using the hardware
acceleration.
So it's not a free lunch.
If you want to use that, if your
WebView is very large, we
still have to locate
the [INAUDIBLE].
You're also going to
use some memory.
So in some cases, that
may be a wash.
Bottom line, if you don't have
too complicated content, you
may want to use the software
rendering.
It might be a better idea.
You lose some things.
You know, you have CSS3D
or inline video.
But that might be OK.
Right.
How do you get hardware
accelerated view?
Well, if your application is
accelerated, the WebView is
simply going to be asked
to be drawn on to
an accelerated canvas.
And from then, we
know what to do.
If you want to force
the 2D rendering--
so let's say that you have an
application that is hardware
accelerated, which
I hope you are--
you may just want to specify
the layer type to software
just for the WebView.
And that's going to trigger the
2D rendering code path.
So one nice thing is
accessibility is supported.
So if you want to have
accessibility in your
application in Java WebView,
you basically don't have
anything to do.
Just one thing, try to enable
JavaScript because then we
support more things like Explore
by Touch, or Gesture
Navigation.
And it's basically
the same solution
as Chrome or ChromeOS.
So if you want to make your
content accessible, you can
test that on Chrome.
It's going to work on
the WebView as well.
If you want to implement inline
and fullscreen video,
one little [INAUDIBLE], and
this one talking about it
here, is that we don't
know how to display
the fullscreen mode.
We have just a normal view.
So if you tell us, OK, I've
got a video and I want to
display fullscreen, we don't
know where to put it.
So you have to give us a view.
And when we go to fullscreen
mode, we'll just redirect
video texture to that one.
So that's how you do it.
You just have to implement
onShowCustomView and
onHideCustomView.
The interesting thing with the
WebView is that you can bind
the JavaScript code to
your [? direct ?]
code.
You do it in a very
simple way.
You create this class.
And here I'm just defining
the shortest method.
And that takes [INAUDIBLE]
as a parameter.
And if I call that function,
JavaScript is just going to
show me this little toast
message on my application.
How do you bind that?
It's very, very simple.
You just create an instance of
that class, give it a name--
so here, that's Android--
add it to the WebView.
And from then on, if you call
Android. showToast in
JavaScript in your WebView,
that's actually going to take
that bridge and execute
the [INAUDIBLE] code.
All right.
You can use the viewport
tag as well.
That's a nice way of specifying
things like are you
letting the user zoom or
not in your content?
So if you have a web app and you
know explicitly that your
content is not going to be
zoomable, maybe you want to
prevent a user to do that,
that's going to provide a
better integration with your
app, you just do it that way.
There's a bunch of other
parameters that you can use,
but the documentation
is there.
Let's talk again about the
layers and the animation.
Basically try to remember,
use layers.
And if you have been to some
of the other talks about
Android, this is exactly the
same problem and the same
solution for the hardware
acceleration on the Android
application.
So the typical way that you
would then animate some
content in a web page or in
your web content, you get
element, [INAUDIBLE]
left and top of that element.
And that's basically the
worst possible way
that you can do something.
What you can do instead is
move that to a layer.
And you can do it very simply
by just applying a CSS
transform 3D.
Even if it's, as here, a
completely empty transform,
that's going to move that
content to its own layer.
And then moving it around is
going to be much faster.
Ideally, don't even use the left
[? enter, ?] because the
left [? enter ?] may trigger
some [INAUDIBLE] in WebKit.
So just use the translate 3D
with the right parameters, and
that's probably the best way.
So as an example, if you want to
take this and move it like
that on the right, how
do you do that?
Well, in JavaScript, you would
do something like that.
And basically, you call this
run function, you set a
timeout so that it's
called again.
You get the delta, you see how
much pixel you need to move.
And you specify the
left element.
So two things here.
First, it's actually a pretty
complex piece of code.
Second, it's going to
be really slow.
So if you try it on your tablet,
it's going to be
something like that.
And the reason is because
you're going to
have to go to WebKit.
WebKit may be busy doing
a left [? top. ?]
We have to generate
new content,
send it back, repaint.
It's not optimal.
In CSS animation, that's
how you do it.
That to my eyes is much cleaner,
much more readable.
And it performs a lot better.
So that on the same zoom tablet,
which is not the
fastest device in existence.
And that's actually running
on only Chrome or
ICS, I don't remember.
So the CSS animation basically
gives you a much fast content.
It's v-synced, it's
higher level.
And you can do pretty complex
animation as well.
And the way it works is because
basically for elements
that are animated, you are
going to create a layer.
And as we saw, layers
are much nicer.
So you can do complex animations
like that.
And that's very easy to do.
You just set up for each element
a small animation.
You can imbricate things.
It's really nice.
So I talk about layers, and they
are nice, and all that.
how do you get layers?
Well basically, you've got
a few rules in WebKit.
And those are the rules.
If you apply a transform3d
element, it's going to be put
onto it's own layer,
et cetera.
For the video, for the
canvases, for the CSS
animation, all that is going
to create layers.
As I said before, on Android we
are actually using layers
to do more things.
So we got additional rules.
So if you are using a fixed
position element, bam, layer.
And et cetera.
OverFlow-scroll, and iFrames,
canvas, fixed background
update, all these things are
going to create a layer.
The thing to remember, though,
is that even if they are on
their own layer, this is a
purely implementation detail.
The content is going to
be visibly the same if
you don't use layer.
It's just going to be much
slower to render.
Of course, I mean if you
are in CSS 3D, that's
not going to work.
But that's a special case,
because we don't do the
transform, only 2D.
So basically, if you have
content that you are
animating, put it
onto a layer.
Now, the thing you have to
remember is that creating a
layer is not cheap, because
you have to
basically do two repaints.
You have to remove that content
from whatever surface
it was, repaint that surface,
then create more textures and
paint those textures as well.
So all in all, it's a pretty
expensive operation.
So a typical trick is just,
well, if you know that
something is going to be
animated, move it onto a
layer, keep it there.
I mean, above all, don't do all
the back and forth all the
time between I'm on
a layer, I'm on a
base surface, et cetera.
The tiles are 256 by 256,
at least for now.
And you may take advantage
of that.
So if for example, you the
viewport tag to specify that
you are working toward the scale
of 1.0, you can then
make sure that your content
is going to fit on
just a single tile.
Then it's going to be much
faster than if you are just
one tile and [INAUDIBLE].
You can't always do that.
But you can, think about it.
There is a slightly different
code path for images.
If you are using images, and
let's say that you are using
lots of images, you may want
to apply the [INAUDIBLE]
directly on the image element
not on the [INAUDIBLE] that
will contain that image.
And that basically lets us just
get that image, and we
can reuse it.
And we just have to run
the rates at scale 1.
And we let the GPU
do this scaling.
And as I said, you may want to
try the software rendering.
That might be nicer.
While I said that you should not
use JavaScript, we still
did implements, improved
stuff in JellyBean.
So stuff are not as
bad as they were.
But yet, I would say,
if you can use CSS
animation, much nicer.
All right, so one of the typical
issues that people
have with the WebView
is synchronization.
And by that I just mean, only
synchronize what you are
showing on screen with
the Java stuff.
And so if you remember that
previous diagram, we create,
we get an event, we create
a new picture, we
send it to the UI.
Before when we were just using
the 2D rendering, we were
receiving that picture, and
basically we could just draw
it instantly.
So we had this onPicture
[INAUDIBLE]
callback that is
not imbricated.
That when we were receiving it,
you would know that, OK
that's the new content.
But now of course, things
are different.
If you create your picture,
we send it to the UI side.
You get that onPictureChanged.
But between the time you receive
that and the final
rendered content, there
is a delay.
And something that's not great
because how do you know that
what you send to the WebView is
usable is binary rendered.
So the solution.
We don't have an API for that.
But we have a solution that
actually works everywhere.
And that's by using the fact
that the CSS animations have
to be synchronized.
So what you do is you create
the bridge objects.
So here, we just add this
finish rendering method.
And we just add that
to the WebView.
And the simple test case here
is, I've got an application,
I'm having WebView, and I'm
loading the content in my
WebView, and I want to show some
text before the content
is displayed saying, your
content is loading, or
something like that.
When the content has
been loaded, you
can remove the text.
And that's what the finish
rendering method does.
You just set the visibility of
that text view to invisible.
So we just create an instance
of that, add it to the
WebView, call it Android.
And the CSS Magic is here.
You are going to create two
CSS rules for one element.
One is just to move that element
to a composited layer.
So we'll use that code path.
The second is to say, if you are
on the class finish, do a
slightly different translate so
that we will wait for that
transition to happen.
And for internal reason, you
have to give us something more
than zero milliseconds.
So if you got that, on
the HTML side, that's
how it would look.
You would add your content,
you would put your own
transition element, example, at
the end of the body so you
know that the rest has been
loaded, and blah, blah, blah.
And when stuff are loaded,
you call load.
And that's a very
simple example.
If you have more complicated
content with images, or things
like that, you may want to have
JavaScript on there on
the onload event of
those images.
You get that, and the load
implementation is basically
saying, when I'm loaded, set
the class to finish.
And add an event listener
to that element.
When the WebKit transition has
finished, then you can call
the finish rendering method
of the final [? Android ?]
object.
And basically that says to us,
OK, when you're loaded, use
this CSS finish rule.
And when that rule has been
fully executed, and we know
that because we got this
event [INAUDIBLE].
And then we call the callback.
And at that, you are
synchronized.
All right.
So let me talk a bit
about the debug.
OK, you've got all this.
I'll do debug this content.
There's a few things.
First thing you can do, you
can use a console, the old
school just output [INAUDIBLE]
in your adb logcat.
You can do that in JavaScript.
You know, if you get adb
logcat, that's how
it would look like.
So of course, you can do all
the typical stuff in logcat
feature and whatnot.
You can actually specify or
use different logcat level
here, the same as you
would in Java.
One thing you can do, though,
is you can intercept those
message calls for
your WebView.
And then you can do
whatever you want.
All right.
One thing that's pretty useful,
if you are into
testing, is Selenium
WebDriver.
And it basically provides you
a testing infrastructure for
your estimated content.
For mobile, the nice thing is
that it supports the touch,
gestures, you can take a
screenshot, compare it to a
previous taken one, so you know
that your tests are going
to pass on it.
And more information
are there.
The way it works is
pretty simple.
That's an example
of a test case.
You create a WebDriver,
tell it to go here.
And we just open google.com.
We look for the web element,
we can send keys, submit.
And when we get that, we can
get the results, and assert
that it corresponds to what
we are looking for.
So anyway, that's just testing
infrastructure.
So if you have content, not just
simply present content,
but are doing more interaction
with the user, you may want to
look into that.
The other thing that you can do
is use the Android Browser
debug mode.
So I mean, if you try your own
unique [INAUDIBLE], the
Android browser is not
there anymore.
Your Galaxy Nexus
is still there.
So it's not a perfect mode.
And we are working on it.
But if you have the Android
browser, there is a bunch of
stuff that you can do.
So the simplest thing is you
can enable that mode.
To do that, you just
go there, type
about:debug, you press Enter.
And it's just a toggle.
So it's going to trigger on and
off this Debug when you
[INAUDIBLE]
in the settings of
the browser.
And here, there's a lot of
interesting options.
Probably the one you are
interested in are UAString.
So you can specify a different
user agent
string for the browser.
So you can easy to test if your
content is really not
working, or if it's just because
the website is sending
a different content, depending
on the UA.
The other really interesting
thing, if you are trying to
[? implement ?]
performances, is the
Visual Indicator.
So if you enable it, that's
what it would look like.
And here, you can see all the
tiles that I was describing on
the Google I/O web page.
If you look at the tile, that's
basically what you have.
As useful information, you got
the coordinates, you got the
scale factor.
And as I, said, there
is a new web app.
You may have some interesting
optimizations to be made in
terms of with the
scale factors.
So you can tailor the images
that you are showing, or
things like that, and prevent
user to zoom around, or using
the viewport tag.
And the last thing is just
the painting time.
That's with CPU time, so that
does not account for the
entire pipeline.
But that can be interesting if
you see that some of your
contact is very slow for
whatever reason to show up.
That could give you
some hints.
The other thing is some of the
element, like fixed element,
are shown in a different
color.
So if you remember that I/O
web page earlier, it was
showing the positioned
elements.
This is just using a slightly
tinted red background.
And the other thing is you can
see if I take this example and
I zoom, that the tiles for the
Android are actually at scale
1.0, while the rest of the tile
are at scale 2.70, which
is the scale I was zooming
in at the time.
And that's because we've got
this optimization where if you
only have image on your layer,
we are not going to go further
than 1.00x.
So that's, again, another
optimization that you can do.
You've got a bunch
of debug commands
that are pretty useful.
One of the nice ones
is RenderTree.
That's going to basically create
a renderTree.txt on the
[INAUDIBLE] card.
We can grab that using adb.
And that's how it looks.
It basically shows you the
rendering tree of WebKit.
So that's a bit involved.
But if you want to read DIVX
tag, that can be quite useful.
The other interesting one
is the LayersTree.
And that's actually a problem in
general with Browser and in
Orchid WebView is that
there is no good
debugging tool for layers.
We provide that [INAUDIBLE],
which just gives
you the tree of layers.
And if you look into it,
you can, for example,
look at layer ID.
And this is a fixed element on
the Google I/O web page.
And you could see because
there's those fixed left,
fixed up, fixed right,
and stuff.
But if you look at the layer ID,
that corresponds to that
blue number on the layer.
So that can be helpful.
It's not optimal.
We can definitely do
things better.
But there is definitely a lack
of good tools to deal with
layers and stuff like that
even on the desktop.
Just as an aside, as we are
using WebKits as well, if you
do stuff in Safari or Chrome
and use their debug tools,
it's probably going to go a long
way in terms of debugging
your content.
But you don't know
what follows.
You don't know that the layer's
architecture is not
exposed, so anyway.
One thing that we are working on
that's not ready yet is to
actually not use that anymore.
But instead, we are going to
deliver HierarcyViewer.
And if you don't know
HierarchyViewer, definitely
look into it.
It's a really nice tool that
basically lets you connect to
your application, and it's prone
to viewer hierarchy.
So what we'll do is that when
you have a webview instead of
just showing this rectangle
same webview that's not so
useful, you can see here
that we can show the
entire tree of layers.
You got a bunch of information
about the layers.
You can grab the content
as well.
And all kinds of interesting
things.
And that's it.
So actually, I was faster
than what I thought.
So if you have any
questions, the
microphones are on the aisles.
And you should just
go to microphones.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Sorry in JellyBean,
if I make a web app just for
JellyBean, would the WebView
use the Chrome for Android?
NICOLAS ROARD: No.
AUDIENCE: No, still use
the old browser
rendering, and all that?
NICOLAS ROARD: Yes.
So I mean, the reason
is pretty simple.
I mean, the WebView is part
of the platform, and
Chrome is on Market.
So if you update Chrome and
Market, we can't replace the
implementation of the WebView.
And even if we wanted, we might
not want to do that,
because that could break
compatibility.
AUDIENCE: We are using app
cache within WebView.
So different OEM I'm seeing,
update, even some OEM
[INAUDIBLE].
On the same level, for example,
Honeycomb, or
[INAUDIBLE], same version level
but different OEMs,
browsers, triggers update
ready event,
some of them don't.
So it's very difficult to
implement this app cache
within the WebView.
Have you noticed this problem?
Or is it something you
guys are working on?
NICOLAS ROARD: I'm not sure
I understand the question.
It's about triggering ready
events on app cache?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, update ready
events, or we can refresh the
page, so with the new content
within the WebView.
So that if you rely on the
update ready event, then I can
refresh the while view,
so I get the new
content on the browser.
But some of the OEMs,
I see update ready
event is not firing.
So it's on the same
[INAUDIBLE]
version, but different OEM has
different ways that update
ready event files.
NICOLAS ROARD: I'm not sure.
Can you come to see me after
the presentation?
Because as far as I know,
things are working.
But we can look into it.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I have
one question.
Can I use the DVtool of my
desktop browser to [INAUDIBLE]
the WebView in my phone?
NICOLAS ROARD: So you mean, to
use your DVtool to connect
directly to the WebView?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
NICOLAS ROARD: That's
not doable.
But as I said, if you're using
a browser on your desktop
that's using WebKit, we are
using a recent version of
WebKit as well, and things
are pretty similar.
And there was a lot of things
that we improved in the latest
version on ICS and JellyBean.
So we are very comparable
to a desktop browser.
So if you try stuff on the
browser, it should work pretty
much the same on the WebView,
with the caveat of all those
performance and the various
tricks that I explained today.
AUDIENCE: Hi, right now you
guys have the ability to
synchronously call from
JavaScript into native code.
I was wondering if you're going
to be able to do that in
the reverse?
Sort of like on iOS, there's the
ability to get string by
[INAUDIBLE]
JavaScript string, how
you can get data from
JavaScript int native.
I was wondering if you're going
to implement something
like that, or planning
on Android.
NICOLAS ROARD: So I mean, the
way you do that, and you can
use the bridge object.
And you can just pass increment
to whatever you
define in your class.
If I remember, the data type
that we do support are
strings, and you stuff
like numbers.
But you can pass some content
from JavaScript to your Java
UI that way.
In terms of synchronous, that's
not the case right now.
And [INAUDIBLE]
that's very likely not going
to happened, because in
general, so you want to have
an architecture that is
asynchronous.
Otherwise, you are going to
possibly pause the UI.
And that's going to be great
in terms of the user
interaction.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I have
two questions.
The first is during your
presentation, you were talking
about adding something
on the new layer.
Do we have to do something on
the down structure before, or
just applying a CSS tree for
[INAUDIBLE] is enough?
NICOLAS ROARD: Yes.
So basically, you've got
those various rules.
That's going to decide, OK, I'm
going to take that element
on my DOM, and move it to a
layer, and the typical one
that are in WebKit.
And that, by the way, is
actually true of any
WebKit-based stuff, both
on mobile and desktop.
The only thing, that may not
[INAUDIBLE] rendering.
But if you do a transform3d,
those are the
common rules in WebKit.
And that's going to move that
element to a layer.
So that's all you need to do.
And the typical trick that I've
seen people using is just
to do a [? translate 000. ?]
The one caveat is that it needs
to be a translate 3D,
and not a translate 2D.
That's enough to promote that
element to its own surface.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so everything
is done by your browser.
And the other question
is very, very quick.
There is no plan to import the
Chrome Dev tools on the
default browser, the WebView?
NICOLAS ROARD: You know, that's
going for [INAUDIBLE].
But right now, I'm not sure.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Good presentation.
I was wondering, the CSS
animation, is that all static?
Or can you dynamically change
it based on user input?
NICOLAS ROARD: Oh no, totally.
I mean, here I just show example
where you specify it
in text, in your CSS file.
But of course, you can add CSS
styling from JavaScript.
In JavaScript, you can
manipulate the DOM, and you
can manipulate the
CSS as well.
So you can very, very well.
I mean, most people do that.
You respond to you some user
interaction and you are going
to apply a new style in CSS.
And that new style happens
to have like
translate 3D, or whatnot.
But as I said, it's generally
pretty costly to get an
element from a base
surface to its won
surface, to its own layer.
So if you can keep things on
layers, that's better because
then we don't have to do
this back and forth.
It's not always possible.
You know, you may have
too many layers.
But if you can, that's
something nice.
With that being said, we did
improve by a lot the
performances on JellyBean.
But even on ICS, that was
not to super great.
AUDIENCE: One more question.
So it currently supports
intertranslation, rotation,
and autographic transformations.
Any plans to support the Specter
transformations?
NICOLAS ROARD: It works.
It's supported since
Honeycomb.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for
your presentation.
And thanks for sharing
this information.
My question is, is it possible
to proxy any
web traffic via WebView?
NICOLAS ROARD: That's
a good question.
I'm not sure.
I think there is a few things
that you can do through
WebChromeClient.
But I'm not entirely sure that
they are things that we expose
with public APIs.
OK, so yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
NICOLAS ROARD: OK, so the
question was, what [INAUDIBLE]
to port for DR unprotected
videos?
And that depends on the support
for your unprotected
videos in the HTML5 standard.
So when we will have something
that works with HTML5 video,
then you will have an
implementation.
That's more for WebKit
question than
something for us directly.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
NICOLAS ROARD: Yes.
But you know, things are
not built in one day.
AUDIENCE: One last question.
Someone asked me this yesterday
in office hours.
If you have a view, like on a
tablet, with multiple webviews
on the view, is there a way that
each webview can have its
own session?
Because the cookie manager
currently is a singleton.
NICOLAS ROARD: No.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
NICOLAS ROARD: OK.
Well, thank you, everyone.
And if you have other questions,
you can probably
find me after the talk.
[APPLAUSE]